I am an introvert and I love it and I'm
not alone
introverts are everywhere
and are quiet approach to life our need
for solitary time isn't a flaw it's a
gift but as an introvert it's not always
easy to realize how wonderful you are
the world feels like a place that
rewards extroverts where being loud is
mistaken for being confident and happy
where everyone has something to say but
nobody listens I adore the intensity and
chaotic beauty of the world but it's in
quiet spaces where I feel truly at home
if introversion were more valued by
Society it could make a massive
difference to our Collective future the
unique attributes of introverts really
are a Deep Quiet strength and as Gandhi
put it in a gentle way you can shake the
world
[Music]